there we go all right let's go D for a
little bit of a wait there here we go
let's go with Queens gambit declined
accepted Albin counter gambit none of
the above its declined I was just ready
to play Knight f3 but I'm not gonna do
that just yet maybe I want to go with
like a central expansion down the line
and that'll entail having maybe mine my
bishop on d3 my knight I need to and
there's a difference between Knight f6
and Bishop to e7 on that third move for
black something that I touch on in one
of one of those game analysis videos
I've posted to my YouTube channel
between who was it Geary on the white
end versus Aronian so Bishop d3 night
here you know I'm not gonna go for for
that CH I know I'm gonna do something
different I might I might want to try
for an e3 move before I declare my
LightSquared Bishop sand tensions or not
or not cuz I guess c5 could be played at
any moment my deal with 8/3 is to maybe
play this move real quick and clamp down
on the c5 square but there's now support
for c5 and of course that guys ready to
roll
Queen side fiend keto well what do you
do I'm gonna just take right now I think
can I actually take take and then take
here I'll work with that
this pot is gonna come under some heavy
fire real quick just take like this I'm
assuming the night is gonna recapture
yeah so black with this move is going to
look to control the center with pieces
instead of pawns and I think I go with
this first and what else
ooh now that's definitely different
there's not a better square for this
Bishop so let's get here right now or is
there something better like pawn plush
no I think right here right now is best
and maybe there's some tricks on h7
because there isn't a knight here and
this might already be working could I
take you and get away with it follow up
with the knight check and Queen to h5
I'm pretty sure if I take in the King
recaptures after Knight g5 the King has
to play to one of these two and I don't
know if I have a good follow up like
what if King h6 I don't have my dark
square Bishop around to control this
dark square and I don't know if just my
knight in Queen alone are gonna be
enough so in other words I'm not going
to I'm not gonna do that so let's just
Castle rook c1 purposeful moves risky
one Queen e2 rook after D one and maybe
maybe a pawn push in the center we're
gonna see about that though in the
meantime I have to look into this e5
advance that could be played pretty soon
maybe okay well maybe night there well
there we have it
interesting
let's do this I'm not gonna go with rook
Siwon I'm I'm more interested in getting
my rook on this file real soon and maybe
there's some tricks against this Queen
right now so if the recap if takes I
don't know if I want to capture with my
pond because after Knight f6 all of
these black pieces are in a wonderful
spot to blockade my isolated pond I take
here I think I'm gonna just take there
if I push here the night as that square
available let me just push and depending
on how there's the recapture we could
end up with the hanging pawn structure
okay we're not having that hanging pawn
structure would be my deep on with the
absent and black would have just seen
deep ponds kind of just uh together
let's see I'll push pond takes here hmm
not sure what to do you push that bishop
around a little bit mmm
yeah let's push them around let's see I
think coming all the way back is best
because I do have a d5 move available
and this might be pretty good I wonder
if this is whoa
this might be a winning shot I don't
know if I should call the shot me our
winning move you get the idea cuz now if
the knight moves I have takes if the
Queen tries to get off of this I take
and then take again I think I'm winning
upon and it takes here I recapture and
this is a very annoying pin one I'm not
so sure you could really get out of
takes takes the bishop would have to run
backwards and there's more fuel to be
piled up on it and I'd hear real clear
you name it so now what I think
best-case scenario for black is to just
move the Queen take the knight recapture
I do this and now okay or something like
that the other one okay let's take care
and then I'm gonna chop and chop again
I'm on the Queen and the pun the Queen
could be playing here or there okay now
that is definitely interesting I'm gonna
take and then
take care take another pot like you get
this
and what else okay I better go a bit
quicker let's do this and it may turn
out that what how might it turn out I
think I might want to throw a an
in-between move in here before I take
this pawn yeah let me do that I want to
chase that Bishop to a square where
maybe after I take this pawn I could
then be like landing a fork in sin some
way like right now actually this is
working out I take here or do I let me
try it anyhow this pawn could fall my
opponent has back rank issues that still
need to be solved so that's one good
thing I have I could run away with my
king there's a move that black will be
needing to expend in order to safeguard
their King Knight c7 is soon to be
happening here and I think right now is
a good time for it notice if it was
still on this square I wouldn't have
this fork available again that's why I
thought it might be a good idea to
insert this to not only hit the bishop
but you know what come to think of it
it's also because of a flight Square and
this is is a serious problem this isn't
just me being up the exchange this back
rank me Bishop takes Knight that was a
that was a mistake I'm pretty sure
okay good game let's hit that rewind
button flip the board and see where
either one of us could have made an
improvement so from your perspective
consider you'll see it more like with
the top level play and it's kind of
battling against different plans that
white can maybe be going with should
black go with the knight f6 mm-hmm
opposed to the Bishop e7 move I I go
into more depth with that I'm not really
going to get into it right now but if
you looked up on YouTube Aronian and
gearing its it's the only video I have
out with those two players if you're
interested in knowing and a little bit
more depth the difference between Bishop
e7 and Knight f6 on that move 3 but I'm
so far so good I mean this is this is
all fine I'm pretty sure you could also
consider just recapture with the Queen
or even still maybe just running with
the pawn captures as well I've seen I've
seen Knight capture but I don't know
about this recapture shouldn't go with
the Queen it's the queen capture better
I don't know okay the knight Knight
recapture it's not it's not losing or
anything I think this is quite playable
but now right here I think this is where
there's some trouble because by force I
guess you are down upon though I push
your bishop away and then after
following up with that Bishop move your
and you're in some serious hot water so
where's there an improvement after my
rook plays here I think you'll want to
maybe capture on this square right now
and then do something about getting out
for the same file of my rook if takes
and I recapture it the pond and I don't
think I would but again if I did capture
like this and you saw me recapturing
isolated Queen pond you'll on a blockade
this Square and you're you're in a
position right away with all three minor
pieces after a knight f6 month so if you
take here and I recapture with my knight
maybe you could be playing your queen to
like be eight or something it's a little
bit tricky with your queen still she's
the toughest piece to get working and
kind of dodging the eventual two white
rooks bearing down on these CD files and
night moves maybe to b5 controlling that
c7 square but I don't know I think you
definitely cannot go in for this Knight
d5 move because it does turn out to be
quite forcing or at the very least right
here maybe consider capturing with the
pond that's another thing you can
consider capturing at the pond even
though it makes your bishop look a bit
silly we're working with the hanging
pawn structure might not be might not be
so bad but you'll definitely have to
sidestep do something other than this
Knight d5 move at this point